[Musique]
nous avons enquêté sur la pratique
opportuniste de certains médecins
spécialistes est ce que nous avons
découvert est inquiétant certains
médecins abusent du système à n'offre
des médecins qui gagnent plus d'un
million de dollars par année
est ce qu'on en a vraiment pour notre
argent
[Musique]
le cas de l'institut de l'oeil des
laurentides à boisbriand une clinique
d'ophtalmologie est particulièrement
troublant partenariat public-privé un
ppp leur a permis de tirer des revenus
de trois sources du gouvernement du
québec 34 millions de dollars sur quatre
ans pour couvrir les frais
d'exploitation des patients des frais
accessoires 2 millions de dollars dont
certains étaient inutiles et de la ramq
eu leur rémunération qui a fait d'eux
des millionnaires de la cataracte
nous avons fait appel à notre public et
nous avons reçu une centaine de
courriels qui dénonçait des pratiques de
facturation opportunistes des médecins
qui choisissent de travailler le soir ou
la nuit pour empocher des primes de 70
ou 100 50 % des médecins aussi qui
posent des actes inutiles pour les
patients mais payant beaucoup d'abus ne
serait pas détecté la régie de
l'assurance maladie allait donner
mais elle n'a pas le mandat pour
enquêter sur la pertinence des actes
facturés par les médecins le collège des
médecins et lui pourraient enquêter mais
il n'a pas accès aux données
à cela s'ajoute un système de
rémunérations extrêmement complexe dans
les années 80 les médecins pouvaient
facturer 600 actes médicaux différent il
y en a maintenant 11 milles les médecins
ne sont pas plus ou moins honnêtes que
la moyenne des citoyens c'est leur
système de rémunération à l'acte plutôt
qu'à salaires et le peu de contrôle dont
une fait l'objet qui leur permettent de
bonifier indûment leurs revenus beaucoup
plus facilement que pour la moyenne de
travail à lille leur contrat signé un
partenariat public privé comme celui de
l'institut de l'oeil
son signe en catimini ce qui permet aux
médecins de transformer leurs
pratiquants proposition d'affaires très
lucrative au détriment des patients et
du service public
[Musique]